wer auf 2020 zurückblieb kommt an einem
wort garantiert nicht vorbei wirecard
der größte finanzskandal des jahres
dabei hat der konzern doch hoch serie
ist angefangen als zahlungsabwickler für
online glücksspiel und pornos jetzt der
erste insolvente dax-konzern ein boss im
knast einer auf der flucht wäre hätte es
ahnen können ich mich sagt
finanzminister olaf scholz
tatsächlich wurde er schon im februar
2009 10 informiert über untersuchungen
wegen des verdachts auf
marktmanipulation
einerseits super peinlich für den
finanzstandort deutschland andererseits
auch ein stück weit eine chance meint
der olaf das schafft natürlich auch ein
fenster für reformen wenn das interesse
komplett nachlässt dann glaube ich
können mächtige interessengruppen
hintergrund schon allerhand anstellen um
zu verhindern dass jetzt die notwendigen
entscheidungen getroffen werden heißt er
als kleiner finanzminister würde den
nächsten wirecard skandal die ja gerne
mit reform verhindern aber wie denn mit
den ganzen mächtigen interessengruppen
im hintergrund da machst du nichts die
sind zu mächtig ich könnte jetzt fragen
wofür genau haben wir dich dann olaf
aber ich sag lieber herzlich willkommen
zu aktenzeichen xy ungelöst mit
christian ehring
aktenzeichen xy ungelöst mit christian
ehring
[Musik]
liebe zuschauer die kriminalpolizei
bittet um ihre mithilfe
wie konnten wir uns alle derartig
verarschen lassen
wirecard ein dax-konzern
er findet für seine bilanzen einfach mal
1,9 milliarden euro plus sein komplettes
asiengeschäft und keiner hat's gemerkt
weder wirtschaftsprüfer noch die
bankenaufsichtsbehörde bafin bafin ist
eine abkürzung bundesanstalt für
irgendwie nichts 1,9 milliarden erfunden
das muss doch auffallen na ja da waren
schon profis am werk
wirecard hat immer gesagt das geld liegt
auf philippinischen treuhandkonten um
das zu überprüfen hätte man in asien so
sagen meine it-experten regelrecht
anrufen müssen so nennt sich das wohl
dazu braucht man aber so ein gerät oder
auch so etwas hier
wer hat so was deutsche
ermittlungsbehörden jedenfalls nicht
journalisten ja die können es sich sogar
leisten zur recherche auf die
philippinen zufrieden wir schon zu einem
angeblichen firmensitz aber wir trafen
nur einen alten seemann
der hatte keine ahnung von wirecard der
seemann hatte keine ahnung von wirecard
genau wie olaf scholz im fall magath
wimmelt ist wirklich von schillernden
figuren markus braun ex vorstands boss
sitzt in u-haft und arbeitet nebenbei
noch als comedian vor dem wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss er hat zum einen
gemeint irgendwie die 1,9 milliarden
design verlustig gegangen er wisse nicht
wohin
und er hoffe dass die
ermittlungsbehörden die fänden ja das
wäre voll nett weil er hätte dir gern
wieder lieben zuschauer hier sind sie
gefragt liegen die 1,9 milliarden von
herrn rauen vielleicht bei ihnen zu
hause in der sowjet im kühlschrank
einfach noch mal nachgucken wenn der typ
sitzt wenigstens was sie mit dem anderen
vogel dem marsch alec young marschalek
immer noch auf der flucht tragischer
fall der mann macht so einen
sympathischen eindruck sagen alle seine
mutter sagt ihren erwachsenen sohn es
sei erkannt und angeberisch und wenn es
ärger gab habe er stets die flucht
ergriffen
gehen wir davon aus es ist wo unter
einer palme und denkt sich marschalek
mich doch alle am arsch
viele ungelöste rätsel warum zum
beispiel hat diese bald arbeitslose
kanzlerin für die ehemalige porno
bossemeyer karten auch im letzten herbst
in china blockiert
angeblich weil sie von diesem mann darum
gebeten wurde kt zu guttenberg in der
szene auch bekannt als die copy cat
alias doktor doktor alias lügenbaron
alias freiherr von mogel alias der
plagiator warum hört merkel auch so
einen zwielichtigen informanten
sie behauptet heute dass das passieren
kann dass man zu einem zeitpunkt wo man
von solchen unregelmäßigkeiten keine
kenntnis hat man sie für ein unternehmen
auch einsetzt
das halte ich auch für gegeben eben
konnte man letzten herbst gar nicht
wissen also es sei denn sie hätte diesen
wirecard artikel aus der financial times
von 2015 gelesen oder diesel aus dem
spiegel 2016 oder diesen aus dem manager
magazin 2017
aber sonst das politische berlin fahren
ist einfach zu cool dass wir mit
wirecard auch ein global tech planer
hatten sozusagen unser google nur halt
kriminellen deswegen ist die bafin auch
den hinweisen der financial times nicht
nachgegangen und hat lieber die
journalistin angezeigt genau
und weil die mitarbeiter selber mit
wirecard aktien gehandelt haben verleiht
die heute-show dieser offensichtlich
völlig sinnlosen behörde den goldenen
vollpfosten in der auf beiden augen
blind edition
herzlichen glückwunsch ja von mir auch
schön und christian das honorar wie
immer auf sein konto auf den philippinen
nein ich hatte gerade aus durchsuchungen
das geld bitte nach panama sehr gern
alter die erklärt hatte er wieder alles
wahnsinn
inhaltlich stark satire comedy gold ich
habe es noch drauf also ich würde den
kanal direkt abonnieren und auf gefällt
mir drücken wenn ich das nicht so getan
hätte
das war wirklich stark
[Musik]